(audience cheering)
- How are you?
- I'm so good, Kelly.
This is the first time
I have actually come
to your show and I-
- [Kelly] I know it was Zoom last time.
- It was virtual last time.
But I kind of got emotional.
I walked in and I saw all of these people
on the walls that you
have actually interviewed.
You're on like your fourth season.
- [Kelly] I know, it's crazy.
- [Priyanka] Come on.
(audience cheering)
- No. It's so funny you said that.
Cause I had to leave the other day.
I work here in the studio as well,
working on my album at time.
So at nighttime I had to leave
and I had to go out this way
and I never go down that hallway.
And I went down the hallway
and I was like, oh my gosh.
- I mean, I felt that for you.
I remember when you first launch.
- [Kelly] Started, yeah.
- When your first show came out.
- [Kelly] Four Seasons in. Yeah.
- Look at that, babe.
- I know. It's all right.
It's going all right.
Well, good to see you.
Your daughter Malti, is one now?
- She's one. She's 13 months now.
- That's exciting.
- It's amazing.
- [Kelly] How is it, y'all loving it?
- Yeah, it's the-
- Oh my gosh.
- She's the most chill.
Amazing baby, has the best personality.
Laughing all day.
Super curious.
Yeah. But it's terrifying
'cause she bumps her head
like five times a day.
She only wants to play
with wires, foams, sockets.
- Sockets. Yeah.
- Knives.
- [Kelly] She's like, what does this do?
- Not the spoon, the knife.
So it's like constantly like that.
- Oh my God, I remember that.
I'm so glad that's not my face right now.
- The phase is over.
- Yeah.
Oh my gosh. I mean there's other ones.
- Does it get worse?
- It gets different.
It's like, but it's awesome.
I love, my daughter was
curious like that too
and I mean she's totally
gonna give me gray hair
but she's also-
- I definitely have it.
- like super bold.
- Yeah.
- And I love that from a young age.
Like even when she was
like one I could tell,
I was like, she's gonna have a
very good sense of who she is
and like very bold and brave.
- [Priyanka] What's what I feel.
- You'll love that.
- I feel like she's brave.
She knows exactly what she wants.
- Yeah. But it's also
gonna give you gray hair.
- Yeah.
- Me too.
- I think it's starting.
- Nick said that he sings to her, right?
- Yes.
- I think that's adorable.
Like even whenever like
she was in the womb, right?
- Yes.
- That's adorable.
What kind of music?
What tunes?
- When we were in, I mean
for those who don't know,
we had a really rough journey with Malti
and she was in the NICU
for about 110 days.
- I didn't know that.
- And pretty much the
whole third trimester.
And Nick used to go in with his guitar
and I mean, sing to her.
I played my audiobook, you know?
(laughing)
Or movies. I couldn't compete.
- [Kelly] I was like, you could sing.
- Not like that.
- Yes you can.
- Oh.
- It's mama's voice. Yeah.
- Yeah. But I mean I did,
she's the only fan of my voice.
She like loves when I sing.
The only person in the world
And I love it.
- You're such a liar.
You are such a liar.
So wait, you and Nick have a ritual
that I didn't know about.
So it's called Show and Tell.
This is pretty cute. Explain it.
- It kind of isn't a ritual,
it just happened because of necessity.
We both didn't know very much
about each other's careers.
I mean I know of the Jonas Brothers
but you know, it's a different generation.
I was like, I didn't really
grow up with the music.
- Yeah.
- I didn't know the
history even though him
and I both have 22 year careers
'cause he started his at seven.
- Yeah.
- But so we started showing
each other, each other's work.
Like we would sit and be like,
"Oh you know this was the
most traumatic day on set
for me when my first movie."
And he was like, "Oh, this
was my most traumatic show."
And we'd kind of show
each other our careers
or highlights from our careers
and talk about what we were
really feeling that time.
And it's just become this
thing that we do whenever.
- [Kelly] That's cool.
- We're by ourselves at home.
We just go down the rabbit hole.
- 'Cause y'all met and y'all
got together pretty quickly,
right?
- Yeah.
- So it's kind of cool you get
to know each other like still.
- Yeah. I mean we knew each
other for about two years.
- Yeah.
- But we didn't like really date.
We were both in other things.
- Like other jobs and stuff.
- No, other relationships.
- Oh, other relationships. Oh yeah.
(laughing)
Totally. Thought you mean jobs.
- I was trying to be subtle.
- We both weren't sure.
I think that's awesome though.
Like to show like, I don't know,
I just think it's a very cute way
to like get to know your significant other
that you think you know everything about.
But they weren't there
for that whole time.
- They weren't, right?
And I think it's such a fun thing to,
especially both of us have
had such public careers.
We've both grown up in our own way
in front of other people.
- I love that you both
didn't know each other's careers either.
- I know. It's so crazy.
- That's kind of cool.
- I think so too.
- Yeah.
- It's really fun.
Like, you know-
- [Kelly] You're there for
the right reason, both of you.
- And we show each other
our embarrassing moments
'cause you know, that's your person
and you're safe with them.
- And it's funny.
- And I can show him
like my bad performances
and be able to laugh at it.
- Oh, me too. I have plenty.
Well you turned 40 this past year?
I always forget we're the same age.
So do you feel different?
(audience cheering)
I feel like once I hit 40,
I feel like I like life a lot better.
The more I mature, I like life.
But like, I think it's just better.
It's easier, you're wiser,
but like, also like things hurt.
- Yes.
- That didn't hurt or you
can't bounce back as quickly.
- Oh, definitely not.
- Yeah.
- The one thing that happened after 40 was
I like to incubate a lot more.
I like spending time
with myself, my family.
My priorities have suddenly
become really clear.
I don't sweat the little stuff.
But also your metabolism takes a big hit.
You're like, oh, I see that
sandwich for the next week.
- Yeah.
- You know, or that pizza.
And I love food. I live for food.
- [Kelly] Me too.
- I know, but my job is not-
Like, doesn't like the fact
that I love food as much as I do.
So that changes, your relationship
with your body changes.
I used to work a lot.
I still do, I work a lot.
I love my job. I feel very good.
- Me too. I like working.
- I love working.
- Me too.
- I love my job.
But you know, you get tired.
- Yeah.
- You wanna go home
and like nap. You know?
- I'm really looking forward to napping.
After the show, yeah.
- A nap would be nice.
- And a nap, I mean by like sleep,
like solid eight hours.
- That's so so old, Kelly.
- Yeah. I don't know
why I said nap, really.
I mean usually I think
because I don't get a full
night's rest and I need it.
But like, no, I just
mean a full night's rest.
I'm very excited about that tonight.
- Yeah. To be able to leave eight hours.
- Eight hours.
Oh, you get it. Well,
you have a one year old.
You might not get that.
- [Priyanka] It's hard. It's hard.
- we're back with Priyanka
Chopra Jonas, y'all. Give it up.
(audience cheering)
Your new movie is called "Love Again".
So why did you wanna be a part of it?
- It's just, first of all, it's
Celine Dion's acting debut.
- [Kelly] I know.
That's incredible.
- How crazy.
For the rest of time,
I'll be in her first movie
- I never knew she'd do it.
Yeah, that's incredible.
- I just can't believe she hasn't done it.
- I guess I can't either.
- You know?
You would think that Celine--
She's so funny.
- Very passionate.
- She's super passionate.
She came in like such a
professional on this movie.
She helps me and Sam's
character find love.
And we have original music from Celine,
which we haven't had
for a really long time.
And she's grappling with some health stuff
so I'm just really excited
to be able to, you know, see her
and have her fans see
her again in the movie.
So that was a big reason.
But also this movie's a
remake of a German film
and it's just so sweet.
I love a great romcom.
- Me too.
- I love like, you know
what makes your heart smile.
- They don't make enough of them.
- Yeah. We don't.
And I love that moment of being able
to go into the theater,
getting like a bag of popcorn
and sitting and watching a movie
that makes you feel hopeful and happy.
And you find love again.
- It's the opposite of watching the news.
- [Priyanka] Who doesn't
wanna find love again?
- Yes. Some of us don't, but-
(laughing)
- Facts.
- But Nick is also in the movie.
- In different ways.
- Yeah. Nick is also in the movie.
I didn't know that.
So was he just there with you?
And then y'all are just
like, "Hey, come do this".
- Kind of.
- Okay. I love this.
I was moving to London.
This was 2020 and it was like during,
like in the middle of Covid.
- Covid, yeah.
- And Nick was like, "No, I'm
gonna come to London with you,
make sure you're settled
and then come back."
So he was kind of there
with me to support.
And I was filming and
the producers were like,
"Well Nick's here, do you mind?
Can we? Do you think we could?"
Ah, ah.
And I was actually really grateful
that they wanted to ask him.
Because the scene as it
was written is a bad date.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(Kelly laughing)
- [Priyanka] And it's slow
slobbery kissing with an actor.
- [Kelly] Look at Nick's face. (chuckling)
- And it was written like that
and I had to do it with a stranger
like a random person
slobbering slowly on my face.
- No. I've had to do
that in a music video.
And I have a thing with
saliva. It was a hard day.
- [Priyanka] I don't do that.
- That'd be my traumatic thing.
I'd show my significant other.
- I can't do that.
So I was so grateful that Nick,
first of all, was approached.
- He's licking your face.
- And second of all, that it
was my husband that did it.
So I was like, phew. Dodged that bullet.
- Which kinda makes it like
so funny for everybody.
That little nugget in the movie
of like, you're like not
interested in your husband.
- It's so funny.
- It's funny.
So speaking of movies though,
you and I are now the only
people with our own flavors
of Rob's Backstage Popcorn.
(audience cheering)
Rob's backstage. This
is mine, this is yours.
I wanna try yours.
- You haven't tried it?
- No, I haven't been able to try it.
- Oh.
- I asked Nick he was like,
"We'll get you some".
- I think it's very important
for the Rob's, all of the flavors.
- Oh you have to shame 'em?
- You have to.
- Get all the stuff around.
- Yeah, get all the juices.
- I'll have of mine too.
We can share mine.
- Yeah, yours too.
- Wow. That was really loud.
Did you hear that?
- Yours is amazing.
- It was like (imitates bag popping)
I'm used to being on TV, guys,
I promise.
- Hey.
Look at that barbecue, guys.
- It's called Mumbai Night?
Mumbai Nights.
- It's called Mumbai Nights.
Because, so yummy.
Because it reminds me of the Mumbai heat.
Mumbai is very humid and
this has like a kick to it.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- Indian Spice blend.
I use some of my favorite
spices like turmeric and-
- Girl, this is good
- Right?
- I love turmeric
- And like cumin and garlic and onion.
- [Kelly] I'm just gonna keep eating.
- Keep eating. It's great.
- You keep talking.
Oh, they're really good.
You have a new series too,
it's called "Citadel".
- Yes, I do.
- I love this. I'm excited about this.
What is it about?
- It's on Amazon Prime
and it is a spy show.
It's out there now.
You guys should check it out.
- I love spies shows.
- It's a really great spy show.
It's got Richard Madden,
Stanley Tucci, me.
- Great cast.
- An amazing cast of people.
But it's six episodes and
it's a really sick show.
There's never been anything at the scale
of like action stunts
and of the production value of the show.
But at the same time,
it has real heart with characters.
Like my character and
Richard's character have drama.
We have history plus we
have to save the world
and then have to do it together.
- I'm into all that.
- It's so good because of all of that.
- Is the action hard for you?
(audience clapping)
Like the scenes, like the action scenes?
I feel like you're always in things
when you're doing stuff
like that, so I like that.
- I have done a lot of
my stunts my whole life.
But I've also learned to do that
because I mean, I started with,
you know, smaller Bollywood movies
and we never had a stunt
double that was awesome.
Oh gosh.
- What?
- They're gonna kill me for that clip.
- Oh. I'm like, wait, which--
Oh, okay.
- [Priyanka] That's me
pole vaulting over a horse.
- [Kelly] Wait, so I heard about this-
- Which didn't make the movie.
- And it didn't even make it!
It didn't even make it.
And you pole vaulted over a horse.
- [Priyanka] Yeah, a stallion.
Yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] That's a big horse.
- [Priyanka] I mean, I was rigged,
but it is still pole
vaulting over a horse.
- Still looks so cool.
- It looked amazing.
- I would've fought like
hell to be in the show.
- It lives on my phone.
I watch it every couple of days.
- Just to remind myself I did this.
- Reminds myself that I'm capable of that.
But I love stunts and
I trust my body a lot.
I've had a lot of experience doing it.
But, you know, working
with the Russo brothers,
they have such an amazing stunt team.
Like look at all the stuff they've done
with the Marvel stuff.
And you know, their stunt
team taught us a lot.
We trained, it was a year and a half
of training and-
- Wow.
- Being prepared and working on your body
and learning, like there's so much,
so many stunts in this
but it makes you feel like such a sense
of achievement when you watch
the show and you're like, wow.
Like 80% of that was me.
- I look bad-ass.
Yeah.
- And I did a great job.
So it was challenging but
it was gratifying too.
- So something I love to
hear is on your new show,
you actually have equal
pay with your male co-star.
- Yes.
- Yeah. I love that.
Did you have to--
You had to fight hard for that.
(audience cheering)
Cause I know of many of actresses
that have tried to do this
and it doesn't always work.
That's incredible.
- No, it doesn't usually work.
And there are like weird excuses for it
that, you know, you're
not actually co-leads
or you're not as accomplished
or, but in this case-
- Can't hear that enough. Yeah.
- Yeah, I know.
You know, the male actor
has accomplished a lot more
or like, there's always
some sort of debate.
But I've had a 22 year career.
I've worked with many, many
male co-actors around the world.
I have done many as co-leads,
which is what the show was.
So my contract was actually done.
And I remember my agents
at UTA, love you guys,
went in and said, "You know,
you are a co-lead on this show.
You should have
most-favorite-nation with Richard."
And I was like, "Oh really?
I mean, I guess I should, but like".
- That's not gonna happen.
- Yeah.
- I'm jaded enough to be like,
well that's not gonna happen.
I'll take whatever I'll get.
And they were like, "No, let us go back
and have that conversation
with the studio."
They went back to Amazon studios
and they really didn't have any pushback.
They were like, "You're
right, they're co-leads.
They should have most-favorite-nations."
And they came back and they were like,
"Well you have the same
parity and the same pay."
And I was like,
"Wait, that happened?"
- What?
- And they were like, "Yeah, it did."
So there are some people that'll do that.
And now Hollywood's changing.
- Way to go, Amazon.
That's amazing.